Tim Callas show Dallas Morning News
columnist and of course the star of
around the horn joining us on the
program craziest athlete you've ever
been around timís ooh ooh craziest
athlete this is an odd word might go
with will Clark I just crazy eyes and
crazy he would look at you he could be a
good guy I covered him I covered the
Giants for two years in the late 80s
when he was a great player covered in
when he was a not great player with the
Rangers
you know Michael Irvin is probably the
obvious choice for me and and I think
people would back me on that but I'm
gonna I'm gonna go with the wild card we
love to do the referendum on certain
players in certain teams and we do that
with LeBron James with every game and we
seem to do that every week with the
Downloads Cowboys they're either the
team to beat they're gonna go to the
Super Bowl coach should be fired the
reaction after losing to the Colts and
being shut out is what very easy for
everything to fall back on Garrett and
Linehan that they don't know what
they're doing they get no credit for the
time waiting for the players when the
players don't show up or when they drop
passes it's back on the coaches so
that's kind of the theme around it and I
think there's the cowboy cowboy fans are
very skeptical there may be millions of
them but for for good reasons no NFC
championship games for 23 years they're
very skeptical and I think the five-game
winning streak had made a lot of its
things you know they're this team's
gonna win the East and then when the
wild-card gave at home and then we'll
see I'll probably lose but play well
against the Saints Rams and now it's
back to could they lose to Tampa Sunday
could they really need a win in New York
the last week of the season just to win
the East because everything everything
fell apart not just in a cowboy game but
then Philadelphia and Washington winning
games I mean all three of those results
were pretty crazy it just felt like in
teams have these games where you go I
don't I can't explain that and it felt
like that was one of those games like
Minnesota losing to Buffalo where you go
did that happen I know the Colts are a
good team but it it felt like it was
just an odd match up to me can you can
you do it as just a one-off here or is
there is there a troubling sign that
you're seeing the the the troubling sign
is the defense getting it's funny they
got shut out and the thing I take out of
that game is whoa Marlin Mack ran for
139 yards a career-high what you know is
this defense gonna go back to getting
pushed around because that hasn't
happened in a while so that's the scary
part but I think you're right about the
first part the Colts are in this
dogfight with Tennessee and with
Baltimore they got to keep winning just
to have a shot the Cowboys knew after
they beat the Eagles no matter what
stuff Jason Garrett tried to feed him
they had a two-game lead and all the
tiebreakers with three to go they really
and they still don't they probably don't
need to open another game they could
just wait for Philadelphia and
Washington to lose a game so this game
meant everything for the Colts the
Cowboys yeah they'd like to keep winning
but way to win a couple bad things
happened on those early drives the block
kick you drop pass down at the one it's
kind of you shrug your shoulders and go
wow that's not going to happen but what
part of this team can you rely on if I
said that defense come playoff time or
that offense you had to pick one oh I
still go with the defense I don't think
he rely on this offense at all I mean
even they're they're the greatest win in
the last few years is the 13 to 10 went
over the Saints where the offense didn't
score after halftime and especially if
you had said in in Oxnard in training
camp who would the five guys
the Cowboys can't lose you would
probably list it real quickly dak Zeke
DeMarcus Lawrence the defensive end and
then you would have said Travis
Frederick and Zach Martin in the
offensive line and Frederick's of course
amidst the whole year that Sunday was
the first game Zach Martin has ever
missed and then the other guard got hurt
he got poked in the eye and they were
down two guys you know we'd never heard
of about there on the field so the
offensive line hasn't been great this
year anyway
and without Zach Martin did they can't
do anything
it's got to be the defense will still
get them wherever they go yeah I made
out before I brought up a stat yesterday
that you've never had a quarterback
sacked 50 or more times make it to the
Super Bowl and you got two Shaun Watson
and dak Prescott who have both been
sacked over 50 times this year which is
alarming for the Cowboys I know that
it's been a makeshift line there but
that's the those are troubling numbers
as you head into these final two games
and into the postseason
I think they gotta be I mean and I was
surprised I heard that staff and the
Cowboys had never had a quarterback
sacked 50 times which surprised me
further I would have thought Troy when
his rookie year but then you know we
played 11 games so maybe that's why I
did that yeah but yeah I mean and a lot
of those are on deck I he Cowboys fans
get very frustrated with him standing in
the pocket and standing in the pocket
and standing in the pocket here comes
the rush and he doesn't move up but he
doesn't move to the side and and I just
think it's something he's been slow to
develop that he doesn't want to just
turn into a runner he wants to find
something and but those numbers are huge
you're right thank you very much
Watson and dak you're gonna product in
is around 60 so you uh you on around the
horn today I'm on tomorrow and Thursday
I think I think we're winding up the
year I doubt the world next week I
haven't really looked into that but got
two shows coming up this week dan do
don't tell far in advance they don't
wear that nice Dan Patrick show
sweatshirt I received in the Bale did
you get it I got it okay you know I did
27 shows this year I got a sweatshirt
for it I can't tell you how much I
appreciated
wait you were on 27 times no I mean your
show that was exaggeration okay all
right just saying nobody else got
sweatshirts to Reggie Miller down our
junior didn't okay just letting you know
Will Ferrell did how far in advance do
you get the topics for around
we get them we have a conference call at
1930 but they're already in a Google
document email if you want to get up
before the conference call and read them
for some reason about 8:30 you could do
that or you can do like me and skip the
conference call he's busy writing your
column or you're on this show or doing
this show which they have noticed number
of times yeah you don't have time
because you always tend to ask me to be
hot around 9:30 okay you have to wear
that sweater okay can you get through a
whole segment with a mothership lets you
get through a whole segment with the DP
show I'll promote the hell out of this I
mean I'll give you a lot of publicity
I'll triple the ratings of around the
horn but I mean come on you got Yeats
who wears goofy things woody where's
goofy things let me take a look at my
contract let me see what that says I'd
love to do it okay it'd be kind of nice
it'd be a nice way of saying hey this is
for the Dan Patrick show audience just
want to give them a shout out they're
down trying you know they don't have
much going on in their life because now
they're listening to Dan Patrick after
he left ESPN so ok you could do that
yeah that would be nice all right so
which day am I looking at tomorrow are
you lying to me Tim let you know I have
it and I'm thinking about it let's give
a Thursday from the rod okay but you've
got to give me a heads up send me at
hours if your heads up don't send me
pictures of your girlfriend send me
texts of you with this well send a
picture of your girlfriend but as
beautiful as your girlfriend is is she
still your girlfriend yes we just went
to New York this weekend saw King Kong
and waitress oh okay
couple couple plays well that's some
calling very good yeah you're in love I
mean that's that's great went to dinner
with Tony rial
Lenny Kravitz was in the little Italian
restaurant just to do some name dropping
yeah well done well done
okay so Thursday sweater time
Thursday's a target and if it doesn't if
it's a no-go
I will call off the call off the dogs
okay all right I'm gonna watch either
way because that's that's what I am we
need some numbers do you like the new
graphics no kind of bold no bold colors
no no no yeah because they're going to
replace you with a hologram one day Tim
and I'm worried about that like reality
is gonna be the only guy on that show
and then they're just gonna put I mean
you guys look fake as it is so I know
where reallies going cost-cutting we
already yeah we already look too good to
be true yeah all right so Thursday we're
gonna be watching around the horn is Tim
Cal sha shocks the world and the
mothership and he risk his jaw just to
wear dead yeah a sweater awesome
Tim thank you as poorly how many deaths
do you have there back there by Perloff
and everybody mmm do you have another
one that I could I will add I will build
an addition okay I will build the Calais
Shaw addition this okay you can stay in
here too if you'd like to bed you can
stay in the man cave nice restaurant
downstairs we got it all for you but
we'll be watching on Thursday it'll be
one of the great moments in the history
of the Dan Patrick show
thank you Tim as always and Merry
Christmas all right that's Tim Couch him
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
you
[Music]